chameau ou à toucy boeuf décosse et
chevaux miniatures c'est une véritable
ménagerie qui a débarqué à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
arrivé cette semaine le cirque nicolas
zavatta se prépare pour les premiers
spectacles de l'année
la première date 2018 alors faut qu'on
mette un peu tout en place on a pris pas
mal de retard à cause de la neige cette
année pour nous le thème c'est sur le
brésil parce qu'on a une coupe du brésil
qui va nous faire un magnifique numéro
de trapèze volant à numéro de sangles
donc c'est sur le thème du brésil cette
année mais cherche toujours à la fiche
des grands clowns cirque zavatta obligés
d'avoir des collaborateurs depuis huit
générations la troupe parcourt les
routes de france et d'europe
l'an dernier elle avait déjà fait escale
à saint quentin en yvelines
en plus du nouveau spectacle les
visiteurs pourront découvrir un nouveau
chapiteau
je suis
la nouveau design des nouvelles couleurs
et oui elle est plus grande en
accueillir un peu plus de personnel que
personne que d'habitude on était à
environ 1000 places on peut aller
jusqu'à jusqu'à 1500 cette année et
c'est un monde de rêve vous savez aussi
bien pour les artistes quand ils font
leur numéro qu'ils apportent du rire de
la joie au public comme au public
normalement ils nous disent toujours
qu'ils sortent avec les yeux pleins
d'étoilés un spectacle dans la pure
tradition du cirque tel qu'il a été
inventé il ya 250 ans les trente
artistes et leurs animaux seront
présents jusqu'au 28 février à lille de
loisirs